hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 19 video also
kind of like a soft crossover with arrow
just like we had last week I know
everyone was playing up the episode 18
all-star team up episode is like the big
crossover but this was actually a really
big - for reasons that we'll get into
during spoilers so just careful if you
haven't seen the episode yet and yay for
Green Lantern pizza okay so here we go
starting with top 5 WTF moments number 5
Cisco gives Laurel her canary cry one of
the biggest questions I've gotten all
season is you know will there be another
particle accelerator explosion and will
Laurel get canary cry powers as a result
of that this is the answer she's
basically using tech if you ever watched
young justice you know canary wears the
choker think of this as like a tech
version of that cisco explained that
it's super beefed up so it'll be super
badass though they'll probably use it
before the end of the season because the
episodes are staggered I don't know when
we're gonna see this being used in an
episode of arrow it might be like arrow
episode 22 it might even be the finale
the picture that Laurel gave to Cisco is
the funniest thing in the world he's
like the biggest Black Canary superfan
let me know which picture you think is
funnier Cisco's picture with the Black
Canary or the picture of Stephen Amell
like the actor headshot they used the
clammer shot in episode 19 onto number 4
meet Hannibal Bates aka everyman from
the comics if you're not familiar with
the character everyman came around the
Infinite Crisis time in the comics Lex
Luthor created a program called the
everyman project where he gave powers to
people that wanted them it was part of
this secret plot to control people with
superpowers like he could take away
their powers with the push of a button
obviously we're not gonna see Lex Luthor
on the flash so this is just like the
Flash's version of Hannibal Bates it's
interesting that he can't remember who
he really is he's changed into so many
people also when Harrison said that it's
meant to highlight the balance between
the original Harrison wells and eobard
thawne inside that one body the
producers said that when the
reverse-flash sucked in all of harrison
wells it kind of melded their minds a
little bit together so there is some of
the original Harrison wells mind inside
that body
it'll probably explain how they can
defeat the reverse-flash at the end of
the season but Tom Cavanagh doesn't have
to leave the show that's gonna get
really timey wimey as a source of
villainy
handle move eights you know not such a
threatening Don I think he's better for
comedy like the Snowberry kiss for
instance that you know that was really
funny moment especially with the the
music cues they use buying it he just
you knew that it was gonna be a funny
thing
I was actually tweeting during the
episode about how it was funny that
danielle Panabaker
didn't have like the classic slap
reaction that you would expect like how
dare you kiss me what's wrong with you
it was a couple minutes after it
happened it was buy it by the time
Kaitlyn had made it back to Barry's
house and found him in the closet cut to
her slapping him to wake him up
think of it as like a delayed slap
reaction I'm not like a huge shipper on
the show but it is funny when they sneak
moments in like that in there is we do
have an idea of like where Caitlin and
firestorms characters are going so if
you've seen those spoilers just please
use spoiler tags if you're gonna comment
on them the real question we need to ask
now is will Harrison wells co-opt
Hannibal's services in the finale you
know before the finale it just seems
like he might release a lot of
metahumans to run interference on Team
flash while he's in acting whatever his
evil final plan is on to number three
Eddie reveals to iris that he has been
working with the flash this whole thing
with Iris not knowing is causing more
problems than it's solving that was what
that whole cart escape scene was about
iris demanded they take Hannibal to
police station because she didn't
understand what a threat he was eddie
telling iris is just the tip of the
iceberg he hasn't explained anything yet
iris is aware that metahumans exist she
just doesn't know that a full extent of
what's going on there are four more
episodes in the season so I would say
you know by the next like 2 or 3
episodes she'll she'll have it pretty
much figured out that doesn't include
finding out that Barry's the flash
though that that's probably gonna be
some other big WTF moment and she'll
probably figure it out on her own
Barry won't just like take his mask off
and reveal himself if she's gonna be a
reporter and the writers want us to take
her as a character seriously then
logically she should be able to do the
detective work to figure out that Barry
is the flash on her own when Candice
Patton was talking about her character
she called out Lois Lane and in Manistee
Lois Lane figured out that Clark Kent
was Superman on her on her own really
early in the movie actually moving on to
number 2 team flash finds Harrison wells
original body I liked how they kind of
brought Quentin into the episode like
Joe and Quentin have this like dad cop
bro out moment
you would do anything to save your
daughter if you could Quentin knows
something's up he knows there's a dead
body he knows it's probably Harrison
wells he just doesn't know the full
extent of what's going on with the
metahumans and he doesn't know that
Barry is the flash I think he knows that
something like really weird is going on
because everyone saw his coffee rising
out of the cup but he doesn't really
have the context to understand like you
know what the larger ramifications of it
are showing Caitlin the body - I think
won her over for most of the episode you
know there was a big question as to
whether or not she was gonna try and
side with Harrison wells like not
believe Barry but I think seeing the
body was like the metaphorical slap in
the face that she needed and finally my
number one WTF moment team flash makes
it inside the Gideon computer room and
Harrison wells is inquiring with Eddie
Thawne this is like our big endgame
moment so team flash sees the
reverse-flash suit and sees the future
newspaper flash disappears in crisis and
then over on the other side of town
Harrison wells is slowly moving in on
Eddie Thawne so let's start with the
Gideon computer room stuff seeing the
yellow suit was a big WTF but really I
think the bigger surprise for them was
seeing the newspaper from the future
they don't know who Eva bar Thawne is
they don't know that he's from the
future but I think that crisis might be
is is it might be the flash disappearing
because he went back in time to chase
the reverse flash to the night that his
mother was murdered that might be
without is originally from moving over
to the police station
what is eobard thawne's planned for
Eddie Thawne is he going to try and
co-opt his services Eddie right now is a
good person he is friends with very very
good friends with Barry and team flash
that means the reverse flash is probably
going to have to trick Eddie or force
Eddie to help him which means he might
start going after iris iris would be the
way to do that that's a very classic
reverse flash thing threatening to kill
the wife or girlfriends of the flash
over the years so with that in mind
here's my big question for you guys what
do you think that eobard thawne's plan
is for Eddie Thawne I think I've said it
before but what I think the show is
moving towards is like a big WTF moment
whereby Eddie Thawne will have a falling
out with Barry Allen slowly sowing the
seeds for Eddie to become a villain in a
future season whether that season 2
season 3 we have no idea there's still a
bunch of stuff that has it happened this
season the reverse-flash still has all
these metahumans that he can unleash on
team flash including gorilla grodd
that's not for another two episodes
though next week is called the trap so
they're gonna try and set a trap for the
reverse-flash clearly I don't I don't
think anyone expects it to go well be
sure to subscribe to get that video
what's gonna happen next is is I'm gonna
post my non-spoilery Avengers age of
Ultron review don't worry I'll post a
spoiler e-version like after after the
movie comes out worldwide after May
first
a whole lot of science bro it's gonna be
a whole lot of fun so whenever I do post
that video please use spoiler tags if
you're if you're seeing it
internationally and you're gonna see it
before everyone else while you guys wait
for that to drop you can click here for
all my other Marvel Avengers videos I'll
add an annotation as soon as I post the
video and you can click here for all my
other flash videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you